نفع مكتب السيستاني ما نسب على لسان ممثله
في ايران حول الاحتجاجات الايرانيه وفق
البيان كما اشار البيان الى ان السيستاني
ليس لديه اي وكيل يعبر عن مواقفه السياسيه
يذكر ان تصريحات لجواد الشهر الثاني وهو
ممثل المرجع الديني على السيستاني في
ايران نقلت هوسائل الاعلام ايرانيه ندد
فيها بالاحتجاجات الايرانيه وابدا دعما
للنظام الايراني
ياتي هذا التصريح من السيستاني في وقت
توسع رقعه الاحتجاجات في ايران لتطال هذه
المره القطعه الطبيه في البلاد حيث رفع
الاطباء الصوت عاليا بوجه النظام الايراني
احتجاجا على منعهم من علاج جرح التظاهرات
وعلى وجود قوات الامن داخل المستشفيات
واعتقال وترهيب الاطباء وفقا ما كشفته
صحيفه واشنطن شهود عيان اكد دول الصحيفه
ان مجموعه من الاطباء تجمعوا امام المجلس
الطبي للاحتجاج لكن سرعان ما تعرض هؤلاء
الى قمع القوات الامنيه ومنهم من كان بزين
مدني قاموا باطلاق النار وضرب الاطباء
قالت ان عدد قليلا من المستشفيات
الايرانيه تقدم المساعده الطبيه للجرحى
والمصابين اثناء الاحتجاجات واكثر من ذلك
اوضحت الصحيفه في تقريرها ان بعض المصابين
من المتظاهرين توجهه للاطباء البيطريين
لتجنب اكتشافهم واعتقالهم من قبل السلطه
من جانب اخر من السلطات الايرانيه ايضا
الطلاب المحتجين من الدخول الى الجامعات
وعلقت دراستهم وفقا لتقرير قناه مجالس
نقبات الطلاب الايرانيين في التلجرام ياتي
ذلك في ظل التضامن الواسع من قبل الطلاب
مع الانتفاض الشعبيه في معظم جامعه البلاد
وكان نحو 600 استاذ جامعي اصدر وبيانا في
وقت سابق اعلن فيه دعمهم للاحتجاجات
القانونيه للطلاب مشددين على انهم
سيستخدمون جميع القنوات الاحتجاجيه في حال
عدم الافراج عن الطلاب المعتقل